I'm so sorry.
Boston?
Yeah.
Gate 12.
I wanna talk about the plane crash.
What about it?
I was in it.
So, you were in the plane crash?
I mean, I wasn't supposed to be on that plane but I was on it.
And there was this guy...
...who was some sort of... like a secret agent or something.
Ocupado!
And he killed everybody on board.
Pilots are dead.
The enemy shot them.
By who?
Me.
Actually, I shot the first pilot...
...and he shot the second one accidentally.
It's one of those things.
Mayday! Mayday! Mayday!
The next thing you know, I wake up,...
...I'm in my room. I have no idea how I got there.
And then, I go to April's fitting...
...because I have to wear this ridiculous dress.
These other guys, these other agents come.
Ms. Havens, will you join us inside the car for a moment?
They snatch me up. The next thing you know, I'm in Grand Theft Auto on the I-93.
Hey June!
It's a beautiful dress!
Where's the jacket?
Whoa! It is wild!
Why are you touching my hand?
Because I'm here for you.
It makes total sense. April is getting married...
...and that is stressful.
Oh no. No, no, no, no. Ok.
Hi June.
Maybe I didn't make it clear enough but we're gonna have to stick together.
I'm sorry. Who are you?
This is the guy!
I'm a guy!
I'm the guy!
Please, for your own safety, please stay in the booth.
What are you talking about?
Everybody get down. No one follows us or I kill myself and then her.
On three, ready?
Uh huh!
One...
Sorry, I panicked.
What number would you like?
Three. Yeah! Let's just stick with three. It's good.
Okay.